the u.s vice president kamala harris
meeting with the ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky
any threats to your country we take
seriously and we have rallied our allies
and our partners
to speak with one voice
the ukrainian leader made the trip here
despite warnings from the u.s
administration that it might be unwise
to travel given the threat against his
country
later on stage he was asked about
president biden's assertion that
president putin has decided to invade in
the next few days
[Applause]
we stand ready to respond to everything
we cannot remain passive how can you
live in a state where you are told on a
daily basis that war will happen that
tomorrow the advance will happen it
means crushing national currency money
being taken out business is closing can
you live in that kind of country can you
have stability in that kind of country
no
he also questioned why the announcement
of the details of western sanctions
should only come after any invasion
we don't need your sanctions after the
bombardment
after our country has been fired at
after we have no borders after we have
no economy or one part of our country
will be occupied why would we need
sanctions then
nato and eu leaders are threatening
unprecedented sweeping sanctions on
russia but the details are not finalized
i asked the european commission
president ursula von de line about
possible measures such as stopping eu
energy imports and russia being excluded
from the swift banking system
the final
decision will be taken in case that
russia is
beginning a war against ukraine any
military aggression against ukraine and
then it's going to be a political
decision by the european council that is
taken but the preparation for the
preparation everything is on the table
western leaders are not just talking
about sanctions russia might face but
also what a full-scale war might look
like
it will be horrendous and uh
we risk the loss of many many lives and
to have something like this in europe
uh it's hard to imagine but we are
closer to that now than we have been
any time since the at least since the
end of the cold war because we have
never seen
such a concentration of troops and
forces
and such a readiness with all the
different elements in place everything
from of course the high-end
weapon systems to field hospitals to
logistics
to commander control so russia can
launch an attack
with
hardly any warning time
there's a remarkable unity in the words
from eu and nato members here but if as
president biden predicts there's an
invasion soon will that unity persist
when it's time for them to take action
james bay's al jazeera munich